ما هو أكثر
مأساوية أو مأساوية بنفس القدر هو
العمى والاختلاف بين
العالم والمجتمع الدولي
لسنوات عديدة من التحذيرات التي
كنا نقولها بأن هذا قادم، وكانت
إسرائيل تعرف أن هذا قادم في
طريقهم، نحن الحركة الوطنية لإسرائيل.  لقد
وجدت فلسطين، منظمة التحرير الفلسطينية،
طريقًا مختلفًا قبل 30 عامًا، لقد
التزمنا بما يطلبه العالم منا،
الاعتراف بالتزام إسرائيل بالمفاوضات
ونبذ العنف
وبالشرعية الدولية والقرار، وكان من
المتوقع من إسرائيل أن تفعل شيئًا واحدًا فقط وهو التراجع عن
احتلالها ووقف
توسعها الاستيطاني الاستعماري.  لم يحدث ذلك في يوم من الأيام مما
أدى إلى القضاء على احتمالات
حل الدولتين، وكان من
المتوقع من العالم أن يفعل شيئًا واحدًا، وهو أن
يؤيد المسيحيون القانون الدولي بالتساوي على
الجميع فيما يتعلق بأوكرانيا بشأن فلسطين، وقد
فشل العالم في القيام بذلك، لذا الآن لا توجد
مساءلة الآن للجميع  تم
إغلاق طريق سياسي واحد، كل
طريق قانوني بالنسبة لنا مغلق مثل محكمة
العدل الدولية، محكمة العدل الدولية، لقد
سمعت ما قالته الولايات المتحدة أو المملكة المتحدة،
أريد أن أعرف ما الذي يحدث الآن،
ما الذي يحدث الآن، هناك حرب
أعلنتها إسرائيل  بعد
المسلحين الفلسطينيين الذين لا أعتقد أن أصدقائك
حماس ليسوا مؤيدين للسلطة
الفلسطينية، هناك حرب وكما تقول
سيكون هناك
تصعيد هائل، هناك حرب كما ترى، نحن
نجري هذه المحادثة لأن
الإسرائيليين رأوا  ما رأوه
اليوم ولكن شعبي يرون هذا كل يوم،
كل يوم يتم
استهداف الفلسطينيين، قتلهم، اعتقالهم حول
أراضيهم، مصادرة أماكنهم المقدسة،
تدنيس ليس فقط المسلمين ولكن
المسيحيين، لقد كنت تتابع ما
يحدث في مسجد AKA وفي
مجتمعنا المسيحي  الكنائس البصق على
أه المصلين المسيحيين شعبنا يرى
الفصل العنصري يطبق
عليهم طوال السنوات الماضية والأرض
تؤخذ وتتبدد الأمل في
حل سياسي يوفي حقوقهم
وهذا ما يجب أن
نناقشه بخير  نعم أعلم أنني أعرف ولكن أعني
كما تعلم أنه لا
الطيف السياسي الإسرائيلي ولا
الولايات المتحدة ولا أي شخص، يبدو الأمر كما لو أن
القضية الفلسطينية لم تعد موجودة،
ومحاولة حل الدولتين
والدبلوماسية في حالة تجميد عميق
هل يمكنني أن أسألك أولاً قبل أن نصل
إلى هناك ما الذي أدى إلى هذا الهجوم، إنه
في تاريخ معين، لقد مضى 50 عامًا على هذا
التاريخ قبل أن تعرف قبل 50 عامًا
كان أه أكتوبر ستة أيام الغفران مصر
شنت سوريا هجومًا مفاجئًا على
إسرائيل ماذا  هل تعتقد أن هذا هو السبب وراء ذلك
وكان هجومًا معقدًا جدًا لحماس؟
لا أعرف، أنا حقًا
لا أعرف ما أعرفه هو أنه كان الأمر
يتعلق بالوقت الذي كنا نصرخ فيه
كل يوم، لا تترك أحدًا.  فراغ لا أه أه
أغفل ما نقوله انتبه
لا تستهين برغبة الناس في
الحرية لإنهاء
العبودية والسبي انتبه إلى
الدمار الذي تفعله إسرائيل
تأكد أن هؤلاء المتفوقين في
الحكومة الإسرائيلية لن يذهبوا
لقلب الأمر برمته رأسًا على عقب، افعل ذلك،
وبالتالي فإن الأمر لا يتعلق بالتوقيت،
وكل هذا يتعلق بحقيقة أننا
نناقش كل شيء باستثناء الشيء الأساسي،
والقضية الأساسية، والأسباب الجذرية،
ونحن نفعل هذا لمدة 75 عامًا،
جملة واحدة لك  اعلم أن 70% من
السكان عند الله الفلسطينيون
لاجئون منذ نكبة 1948
تعلم أنهم تحت
الحصار منذ 2007 أكبر
سجن مفتوح هذا ما يؤدي إلى أحداث
تريد مناقشتها نعم فإليك
الأمر بوضوح  سيقول الإسرائيليون أن
هذا ما يحدث عندما
نخلي أه على سبيل المثال انسحب من
غزة وهو ما فعلوه وكما أنت على
حق فهو مغلق وهو
وضع يخضع لحراسة مشددة للغاية ولكن ما
يحدث الآن على سبيل المثال كنت أتحدث
إلى  السفير الإسرائيلي السابق لدى
الولايات المتحدة مايكل أورين وقال تعرفون
حتى أنتم تعرفون السلطة الفلسطينية
كلكم يا شباب الموجودين في أه أه
الضفة الغربية أنتم تحت التهديد من حماس
وأنكم فقط قال مصطفى و
و محمود  عباس على قيد الحياة فقط لأن
إسرائيل تبقيهم على قيد الحياة، وأنك تتعرض
لتهديد كبير من شعبك.
ماذا ستجيب على هذا
الهراء، هراء مطلق،
إسرائيل تكذب طوال الوقت، ما
يتعرض له شعبنا في غزة هو
نفس الشيء في الضفة الغربية في
القدس ولاجئينا ومغتربينا
نحن متحدون بمعاناتنا ومتحدون
بهدفنا وهو إنهاء
هذا الاحتلال وإنهاء هذه
اللاشرعية أه لدينا
خلافاتنا السياسية بالطبع لكننا لا
نخطئ في أن الشيء الوحيد  الذي يجب
أن نتخلص
منه هو الاحتلال العسكري الإسرائيلي
هو الاستعمار هو
نظام الهيمنة العنصرية الذي
فرض علينا أه أه لا نخطئ
في ذلك لذلك هذا ليس شأنا
فلسطينيا داخليا هذا
فشل كل  يجب على الممثل الدولي أن
ينتبه إلى كل
ممثل دولي تراه بدلاً من تعلم
الدروس التي سمعتها اليوم من العديد من
الجهات الفاعلة الدولية، بما في ذلك من
الولايات المتحدة والمملكة المتحدة، التي تضاعف من ارتكاب
نفس الأخطاء، والفشل هو
الخيار الذي قادنا إلى حيث  نحن
ما هو الخيار الآن ماذا
يحدث إسرائيل لا ترد على حماس
البديل هو الحنكة السياسية هي الشجاعة
التطبيق المتساوي للقانون الدولي
نحن لسنا أقل من البشر نحن
لسنا أبناء  أقل الله أننا
متساوون مثل كل الأمم لقد مرت 75
سنة 75 سنة من القمع والدمار الشامل لقد
رأيتم ما
يحدث في غزة انتظروا حتى الغد
وشاهدوا الآلاف الذين سيفقدون
حياتهم وسبل عيشهم كفى
كفى الحل الوحيد هو الاحترام
الناس حقهم الشرعي في تقرير المصير
حق
العودة إلى ممتلكاتهم الحق في
إقامة دولة خاصة بهم والتوقف عن
التهرب من هذا التوقف عن العثور على
منعطفات حولها، لا يوجد
شيء اسمه التفاف للسلام لا يمكن إلا أن
يتحقق  نحن الفلسطينيين وليس مع أي شخص
آخر لأن إسرائيل على خلاف معنا
لأن إسرائيل أخذت أرضنا
لأن إسرائيل تخضعنا
وتضطهدنا وليس أي شخص آخر
وكانت شجاعة المجتمع الدولي هي التطبيق المتساوي
للقانون الدولي إسرائيل
كقوة احتلال  تتحمل المسؤولية الكاملة عن
حماية المدنيين الخاضعين
لاحتلالها، وهذا هو
القانون الدولي. تتحمل إسرائيل المسؤولية الكاملة
للتأكد من عدم تعرض أي مدني
للأذى، وهي تفعل العكس
منذ 75 عامًا، لقد أظهرت للتو في
برنامجك الخاص أنك تعمل.  هل تقلق من أن
هذا البيان الذي تدلي به قد تم
اختراقه تمامًا عندما
يقصف الإرهابيون المسلحون الفلسطينيون المدنيين الإسرائيليين
ويقتلونهم ويأسرونهم ويحتجزونهم
كرهائن، لا كيف يمكنك الحفاظ على
الأرضية الأخلاقية العالية في هذه الحالة، نحافظ على
الأرضية الأخلاقية العالية عن طريق التمسك  إلى
القانون الدولي من خلال العودة إلى
النظام القضائي الدولي من خلال طلب
حكم المحكمة الجنائية الدولية،
فليأت القضاة الدوليون إلى
فلسطين الأرض الفلسطينية المحتلة
ويحكموا،
وسنقبل الحكم إذا ارتكبنا أي
أخطاء أو جرائم سنقبله ولكن
يعلم الجميع أن إسرائيل هي التي
تنتهك كل أحكام
القانون الدولي وآدابنا الإنسانية المشتركة،
هل ترى السؤال الأخير هل
هناك أي وسيط لنا أو أي شخص
الآن يمكنه تهدئة هذا الأمر؟
الولايات المتحدة غير مؤهلة تمامًا وأنا
أتابع ما هو موجود.  قادمة من
واشنطن، تعتبر واشنطن أن إسرائيل
قضية داخلية وليست
قضية سياسة خارجية، وواشنطن تلعب
كرة القدم السياسية بهذا الأمر،
وللأسف، للأسف، كنا
نستقبلها، الحل هو
عالم واحد، المجتمع الدولي، الذي
يجب أن تكون الولايات المتحدة على الطاولة ولكن كذلك.  هي أوروبا،
وكذلك بقية العالم، وكذلك الصين،
يجب على العالم أن يجتمع معًا لإنهاء هذا
الصراع كما فعل مع جميع
الصراعات الأخرى، ونحن لسنا استثناءً، ولحم الخنزير
الفلسطيني، ورئيس
البعثة الفلسطينية هنا، شكرًا لك على هذا
المنظور.